signori siamo ritornati su un cavallo di
battaglia che non riportava da tre anni
se non di più addirittura ragazzi io
oggi vi parlo della mia passione
il giappone 34 anni fa ho fatto il video
della reaction agli spot giapponesi le
pubblicità di giapponesi non sono come
quelle italiane sono prezzo nel senso
buono del termine nel senso che magari
avessi volesse pubblicità che rasentano
il trash ma sono fatte benissimo però
sono trash
dobbiamo vederli insieme questa è la
best già place commercio nel 2018
vorrei precisare che farne farò altre di
queste reaction del sole sport i
giapponesi non so perché non l'ho più
fatta visto che io amo così tanto
giocare per chi ha visto il primo video
sapete di cosa stiamo parlando per chi
non ha visto niente
preparatevi perché voi non avete idea
poi città giapponesi cosa
[Musica]
contatto cosa sto vedendo lo vedete che
lo vede sono fatte da dio ma non hanno
un senso come detto perché c'è un piatto
così ci avevi immaginate che avete hanno
preso un gatto e gli hanno messo gli
occhiali uomo è possibile nel mondo come
povero gatto terran pagato un sacco per
i croccantini tra parentesi questo vi do
una challenge è nascosta ogni pubblicità
io devo capire di cosa si tratta prima
della fine io lo devo dire prima che
finisca non è detto che anche alla fine
si capisca tipo in questo caso non ho
capito però credo sia la pubblicità di
un app di messaggistica non lo so però
io provo a capirlo non so cosa sia ma lo
voglio adesso questa una pubblicità di
bolle di sapone
noi la pubblicità di di una caramella
regalava cos'è playstation hanno
picchiato la sta facendo
e monster hunter mostrante felicità di
moster hunter in giappone per forza
ma cosa sta vivendo 96
ma cosa
[Musica]
grazie ragazzi di pubblico io non
capisco
oppure azzeccato cioè pensate che questo
messo di testa ma io vi prego fatemi
rivedere quel frame
vi prego svegliatemi posso metterlo come
immagine del profilo del canale vi prego
è bellissimo io amo il giappone ragazzi
poi vi chiedete perché amo il gioco ecco
top
questo è il motivo mani 1 euro
mou singh sono un sacco di yen
cos'era non amazon si veda fermi fermi
fermi fermi tutti giordano grande grande
giordano si distingue tonani dai soci
che dite
ma cosa sta già su chi no
[Applauso]
mi sa che punta magari sacri come vita
ti prego risultati e nino o al era il
rame le rame nel raml al granchio da un
galliani ieri e damen questa era un
indiano in realtà non giappone sentito
che da ben vedo telefono bomba telefono
economico o residenti vol sparato come
niente proprio una cottura o ma cosa sta
vedendo
i nemici aggravare la mamma mia ragazza
insomma box ed è una volta si muoia
schmidt i mostri e la e la carabiniera
bisogna non è quella che ha fatto
partire occhio schiuma da barba sulle
guance è una schiuma da barba ok ski una
barba riceva ok ok ci ho azzeccato
ma cosa sta male
ragazzi cosa sto vedendo ma perché
questa era la [ __ ] pubblicità
dell'iphone ma come no vabbè ma fermi
dai io lo comprerei subito così
havel e questa era meno piccante
immagino già la madonna sembrava
vagamente il meme di quello che fa ma
cosa sta ferma perché sì perché va bene
io già non ne posso più non ho visto un
secondo 1
vi prego iddio per che cosa
e poi a me che lo aiuta a pechino sarà
ma cosa mi importa perché la pubblicità
del sushi dei nih ghiri e va bene perché
questa cos'è e poi non c'entrano niente
con la pubblicità in se certe ma in
questa ci sono bambole la pubblicità
dello chantecler magari che ne so se sta
roba
vi prego non dormo la notte gli
spaghetti ma spiegami ti prego no ma io
ma ormai li comprerei
voglio morire però va bene caserta i
power ranger hanno ingaggiato che così
just dance sparando cos'è sta roba che
cosa sto vedendo da che ci scappa
pubblicità di limoni non lo so non ho
parole voglio quest'uomo nella mia vita
adesso e noi abbiamo limoncello loro
hanno questo bellissimo grazie bello sto
liquido verde come lo compro volentieri
stato non gli cade mai come possibile in
tartarughe ninja liquide macchie schifo
però se 3 sogno kissi ma cos'è quella
roba non la compro non è anche se mi
paga un loro ma che schifo
[Musica]
io penso aver raggiunto un limite in
tutta la mia vita però ci sono stati in
questo lago c'è lo stato su quel cigno
che lo giuro però non ho visto vecchi
con le tette
peccato cos'è una versione un po strana
di petto dei futures a in va bene hanno
sponsorizzato una macchina con il
soffitto più alto o mio zio il mio
povero cervello non sa cosa può tenere
ancora è infatti beh credo sia il gatto
più felice del mondo gli rovelli noleggi
in faccia a puoi ordinare il cibo per
gatti
grazie
beh se melo freni lo prendono a sono
chewing gum
ok ma va
ma basta questo contro l'avevo già visto
lo sponsorizzano veramente tanto sto
coso lungo anno mettono il tema di
qualcosa di lungo per sponsorizzare cioè
in anche lungo giustamente giapponesi di
lungo anno le macchine quanti doppi
sensi in una sola pubblicità ragazza si
diventa c'è lei l'ha lasciato per lui
non sapete che lei si era sposata con
lui l'ha lasciata perché lui ce l'aveva
più lunghi io non so che cosa dire in
tutto questo è geniale e trash mai
jinyan allo stesso tempo queste di
lunghezze qua e nessuno l'ha capito
mammamia fantastici
va bene ragazzi purtroppo per me perché
dico io starei a guardassero per tutto
il giorno finisce la riesce nei video
giapponesi ma tornerò molto presto con
altre v action e ad altri sport i
giapponesi quindi schiavi al canale sia
già della campanella così almeno
rimanete aggiornati sui nuovi video
tornerò con prossime reaction ice fatto
giapponesi lo so perché ho abbandonato
sta roba perché la prima volta che la
feci e si parla di quattro anni fa mi è
piaciuta un sacco devono riportarla a
velo riportata quindi tornerà molto
molto presto e noi ci rivediamo come
sempre ad un prossimo video
ciao ciao molto kringe ma va bene così
beh ragazzi
[Musica]